why I don't write proposals I got a
great question from one of my facebook
readers
I love you guys rhyme rain who wrote in
to say Evan can you make a video I'm
making great proposals I'm sending to be
a product designer proposals will be to
various companies fortune 500 or
startups so this is a great question I
don't know if I'm the right or a wrong
person asked on this because I don't
write proposals I don't really believe
in making proposals the reason is I
prefer to build a marketing machine that
attracts ideal customers to my business
instead of me going out and trying to
sell or pitch companies I find that when
people come to you they'd love what you
do they know you're the right person for
their audience
they're already pre-sold on you it's
much easier to start working together
then if I'm going out there trying to
sell myself and making proposals for
everybody I think it's a much better use
of your time to create lasting content
and materials that people love and
relate to and position yourself as an
expert that will draw people in to want
to contact you I want people saying we
have something that we need to reach
entrepreneurs with whose I got to talk
to Evan Carmichael's I got to talk to it
that's what happens instead of me going
out and saying hi mister company please
work with me I hope you'll give me some
you know some business and here's a
proposal this is funny because this this
is something that works on every level
people hear this and say you don't write
proposals
well that would never work for big
clients that'll never work with the
clients that I'm working with I work
with some of the biggest clients in the
world I work with Microsoft I work with
Dell I work with American Express
I signed big deals with these guys
without ever having to go through a
proposal how does that happen it's
because I've attracted them to me
they're interested in talking to me so
how do you go out and do that yourself
okay think about how you can position
yourself as an expert in your field
you're producing content that people
love that people can relate to that
people want to share it's the job with
these companies to know who is an expert
in these fields right if I don't know
what you're selling this is product you
sell it software for example
right if I have a problem and I need
software to solve it I'm gonna go and do
a search
I'm gonna go on Google I'm gonna go talk
to anybody who I know who might know a
company right I'm gonna start doing my
research you should be everywhere you
should be coming up as the authority so
when I come and talk to you
I'm already pre-sold like I want to work
with you I've heard great things about
you
that's how you bring people in typically
my sales process is very fast it's not a
long drawn-out six-month sales process
with huge companies but how it works
here's the thing here's like here's a
little trick to avoid proposals start
small pick one tiny little bit of a
project that you could take on to show
yourself and then over deliver like
crazy
that's the secret when I first started
working with telecommunications company
worth billions of dollars the first
thing I did with them was it's just tiny
one little project one little project
almost no risk for them and let me prove
myself and they love the results so much
that they wanted to do more and more and
more and more
I got upgrades that upgrades and
upgrades you kept increasing the budget
kept increasing the scope and I never
had to write a single proposal for don't
go in bitching this huge thing pitch
something small you know if you're going
up against another supplier and they're
talking to you they're talking to other
companies find a way to get started on a
really small scale you know look at look
at what their processes now look at
where they have pain right now and see
what little one little thing you could
solve for them be amazing at because
companies want reliable suppliers and if
you're over delivering like crazy your
competition's not and they're gonna say
wow these guys are amazing what else can
we do with them and it leads to more and
more more and more work it works this
stuff works and you can get hundreds of
thousands of dollars million-dollar
contracts you can get this without
proposals because they love what you're
doing you're ingrained you may have to
do a contract that's fine you may have
to do a statement of work but it's
pre-sold right they already want to work
with you
so build a marketing machine
stand for something important be the
expert when people do research when
people are talking about you it should
be all amazing things that you are the
guy to talk to in your field and then
when you start talking to clients just
find one simple easy low-risk low-cost
way to get started and prove yourself
because I guarantee you if you over
deliver like crazy you make them happy
they're going to be dying to do more
work with you and that's how you build a
successful business believe those you're
watching they like the video give it a
thumbs up below if you love or hate
proposals let me know put it in the
comments underneath and if you want to
see more videos like this subscribe by
clicking on my face thank you so much
and I'll see you soon